you just get used to getting screwed by
the Jewish media and I'm saying y'all
don't poke the bear too long
Balenciaga has severed ties with Kanye
West following his anti-semitic remarks
on Friday carrying the parent company
behind the French fashion house
announced it would no longer work with
the rapper explaining in a statement to
wwd quote valenciaga has no longer any
relationship nor any plans for future
projects related to this artist
ET has reached out to Reps for both
Balenciaga and yay for comment
Balenciaga previously collaborated with
a Grammy winner on his line which was
sold at Gap he also walked in a luxury
brand summer 2023 show at Paris Fashion
Week earlier this month
[Music]
images of yay in the show have since
been removed from balenciaga's website
balenciaga's creative director demna has
had a long-standing relationship with
both Kanye and his ex Kim Kardashian
foreign
yeah remember the reality stars now
Infamous all black Mech gal look in 2021
that moment was delivered to us courtesy
of demna and when Kim couldn't make it
to the Paris fashion show she posted
these snaps lying in the dirt rocking
Balenciaga alongside the caption quote
when I couldn't make it demna sent the
show to me yeah Bible it's a great look
shortly after walking in the Balenciaga
show Kanye made headlines for wearing a
white lives matter shirt at his own show
at Paris fashion week now people they're
looking for a explanation and people say
well as an artist
you don't have to give an explanation
but as a leader you do yes I think
that's right
so the answer to
why I wrote White lives matter on a
shirt is because they do
it's the obvious thing he later followed
that up with a series of anti-Semitic
posts and comments which led to his
social media accounts being locked and
celebs speaking out John Legend a former
friend of yays called him out without
naming names tweeting quote weird how
all these free independent thinkers
always land at the same old
anti-blackness and anti-Semitism Jack
Antonoff was a little more blunt and to
the point quote Kanye a little bit I
woke up and burst into tears it just
it's it's it's just abhorrent yeah it's
abhorrent Behavior I hope he gets help
meanwhile Jamie Lee Curtis tweeted that
words matter before slamming the
musician on The Today Show what are you
doing
this is it's it's I mean it's bad enough
that fascism is on the rise around the
world but
on Twitter on a portal to pour that in
as if Jewish people haven't had it hard
enough